also alle wollen jetzt kanzler werden
nach wie vor armin laschet und olaf
scholz beide dabei ist eins eindeutig
wer nämlich den größeren banken kraft
gestern haben wir wollen noch mal drauf
schauen hier auf das vorläufige amtliche
endergebnis wahlbeteiligung ganz klein
hier oben versteckt
76,6 prozent das ist so im mittel auch
der letzten bundestagswahlen die spd
also bei 25 7 das ist die entscheidende
zahl für die sozialdemokraten wirklich
ein eindeutiger wahlsieger die cdu/csu
klarer wahlverlierer der lasche balken
geht nur auf 24,1 prozent hoch und dabei
hat armin laschet die partei als
parteivorsitzender übernommen bei
umfragewerten von 37 prozentpunkten also
dass die beiden wichtigsten balken die
grünen landen irgendwo im mittelfeld
14,8 prozent die kanzlerkandidatur von
annalena baerbock hat sich also nicht
ausgezahlt sie dachte sie schafft locker
über die 20 prozent landet bei nicht mal
15 prozent die fdp bei 11,5 verbessert
ihr ergebnis vom letzten mal christian
lindner gestern ja auch entsprechend
zufrieden die afg hole 10,3 prozent und
auch das ist eine wichtige geschichte
dieses langen wahlabends denn sie
punktet vor allen dingen in sachsen und
in thüringen ganz sachsen ist in afg
hand und auch der große teil von
thüringen afd hand und die linke rutscht
unter die fünf prozent hürde und landet
eben doch im bundestag weil sie drei
direktmandate holt zwei in berlin unter
anderem durch gregor gysi einst in
leipzig also dann doch am ende im
bundestag vertreten und was ist denn das
hier ssw in deutschland bekannt als
schwangerschaftswoche in diesem fall
südschleswigscher wählerverband alle die
im norden wohnen die kennen die partei
sie vertritt die minderheit der den dort
eben schleswig holstein und die muss
eine bestimmte zahl an absoluten stimmen
in schleswig-holstein holen und dann ist
sie drin im bundestag sie wird einen
bundestagsabgeordneten künftig stellen
wir schauen noch mal auf die
sitzverteilung im neuen bundestag die
sehen sie hier und da sehen wir erst mal
deutlichen vorsprung für die spd vor
cdu/csu
das sind nämlich zehn sitze mehr als die
union zehn sitze vorsprung für die spd
vor cdu/csu und dann sehen wir hier ganz
unten grau eingefärbt einen eben vom
schleswiger südschleswigschen
wählerverband die linke 39 sitze
geschrumpft deutlich geschrumpft die
fraktion die afg hat sich mittlerweile
sie kritisiert ja immer die etablierten
parteien selbst zu einer etablierten
partei gemacht mittlerweile im bundestag
mit 83 sitzen vertreten die fdp mit 92
und die grünen mit 118 noch ganz herauf
zum schluss der blick so sieht war
deutschland heute früh am montagmorgen
nach der wahl aus kleine grüne flecken
loben das ist nämlich der robert habeck
wahl kreis schleswig-flensburg den hat
er sich unter nagel gerissen während
annalena baerbock ihren wahlkreis in
potsdam an olaf scholz verloren hat ganz
im osten der republik tiefblau das ist
afd land eine wichtige geschichte dieses
wahlabends die cdu ist daraus in sachsen
in thüringen die hat mit armin laschet
diese länder komplett an die afg
verloren im süden noch mehrheiten für
csu und cdu in bayern und baden
württemberg aber auch da überall die
direktwahlkreise geschrumpft nur noch
wenige wahlkreise wirklich deutlich für
die union auch dort im süden und der
rest des landes tatsächlich rot vor
allen dingen im nordosten in
niedersachsen in hessen im saarland in
rheinland pfalz und auch großflächig
hier in nordrhein westfalen halbe-halbe
rot schwarz mit leichter mehrheit für
die roten auch bei den direkt
wahlkreisen und kleine grüne
einsprengsel in nordrhein westfalen
schleswig holstein und vor allen dingen
auch in baden württemberg cem özdemir
der der seinen wahlkreis gewinnt in
stuttgart und dann eben drei wahlkreise
für die linke in berlin zwei und in
leipzig ein dass die geschichte der
wahlkreis karte am montag am morgen nach
dieser so spannenden bundestagswahl
weiter mit dir patricia
[Musik]